yes we got it 100 baths in each store
that's 1,100 in total yeah great start
come on yeah but with my board falls
down to the bare bones I need new
recruits if I'm going to have any chance
of delivering the order
[Music]
the prison authorities have lined up
some candidates but I need to make sure
they're willing to graft I think you
enjoy cooking now my chicken desserts
like apple crumble what you like a
discipline well come on sir it's hard
graft you do that's great news
howdy so your young guy yeah 21 years
old you're not scared of hard graft I my
five new recruits have got a chance to
learn a skill that could provide them
with a future on release
on the outside Andrew Inslee has been
good to his word and kept out of trouble
[Music]
he's landed a job at top London
restaurant roast so I might not be
making as much money is doing off from
the crime but sadly saying it if you
wear you can easy money easy come easy
go with it
[Music]
former junkie Paul Wyatt is also trying
to put his old life behind him his trial
at my restaurant the Savoy Grill was a
success and he is finally fulfilling his
ambition to become a chef Gordon's
helping me stay clean giving me
opportunities to sort my life out and be
the person I wanted to be when I was 16
everything I've tried to do in my past
I've done it but the only one I hain't
done has paid off the drugs
there's known as I stay off the drugs
the other stuff will that be okay as a
recovering addict Paul still got a long
way to go back at the prison we need to
deliver on our first big order hi guys
we got some bodies come in come in come
in I've put old hand tests for Joe's in
charge of the new recruits well get
1,100 that well Friday
should be a piece of cake definite
Opie's cake and this is a showcase so
that one order currently is keeping this
place open so we can't afford to screw
up I'm telling you that he is on the new
team members are keen to impress but the
slice can't go on sale without its
packaging but just ahead of making sure
these are all sliced and ice beautifully
I want to show you something that's what
we're serving you go there you brand
expert Matt Kingdom who had met the
prisoners has designed the packaging
around the life-changing taste slogan
and the personal stories of the team
we're like you know I'm going to be
there for all that basically it's not
true that once your family already from
North you can actually change your name
yeah now you understand the important
ally we're going to give them exactly
this exercise the icing not hanging over
the edge the proxies are needs at my
bakery we have now got a box 1100
exactly like that is handmade simple now
I've got the product that packaging and
the workforce it's labor intensive the
production line can swing into gear but
I've just heard news there's a rumor on
the wings that on the outside Paul Wyatt
has started using drugs again disaster
I'm used to being let down in prison
but it doesn't make what I've just heard
any less devastating